[Musique] la
magie à la
fois belle et puissante
lie notre longue histoire
ce lien commun que nous partageons est l'héritage
de Poudlard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant il est temps d'ajouter votre propre histoire à
ces salles sacrées
et de façonner très probablement l'avenir
de la  monde sorcier
chaque couloir chaque portrait
chaque pierre de ce château raconte l'
histoire des
sorcières et des sorciers qui sont venus avant
ici vous rencontrerez des amis pour la vie et
développerez vos propres
capacités magiques dans les salles de classe des
professeurs les plus talentueux du monde et pendant que votre
voyage commence au
brassage de Poudlard  des potions apprivoisant des bêtes fantastiques
et des sorts de maîtrise il y a un monde plus vaste
au-delà de ces murs
un monde rempli de dangers que vous ne pouvez pas
encore imaginer
une connaissance ancienne depuis longtemps disparue de ce
monde
que le talent étrange et mystérieux que vous
possédez
peut être la clé pour débloquer ce
pouvoir dormant
votre potentiel
est illimité
[Musique]
mais quelle forme prendra-t-il ?
Le voyage à venir révélera
ce que vous représentez
[Musi  c]
les choix que vous faites maintenant
[Musique]
définiront l'héritage de Poudlard